in the early 90s cd-roms burst onto the
scene starting first with computers and
then actually moving to consoles of
course with it became larger asset sizes
as well as increased load times see the
medium of actually getting data off of a
cd-rom was much slower than cartridge
counterparts were for earlier game
systems this mean for the first time in
history game developers were actually
forcing users to stare at a very very
boring screen that just told them
content was loading this of course was
because the assets took time to get into
memory and they weren't being streamed
off of disk fast enough more importantly
game developers didn't really have the
proper knowledge of how to work around
this problem most of the architectures
back then were single threaded which
means all of the file i o was actually
synchronous or blocking so they had to
come up with very very tricky mechanisms
to load data and render that little ui
now for grits we run into the same
problem if a user is on a very very slow
connection it's actually going to take a
lot of time to stream that data in for
our purposes we actually employ an
asynchronous asset loading methodology
which means we can actually render
things to the screen while actually
pulling data in from the net and that's
what we're going to talk about here in
just a bit